استمتعت بلذة التحرير التي طال
انتظارها مع الجنود الذين
أعطوهم لحظات لكل من نجوا
من الحكم القمعي لروسيا في ابنها
للاحتفال بيوم لم
تهزم فيه قوات بوتين الأخرى عبر
النهر.حرية مثل هذا يأتي في المدن
والبلدات في كل مكان  عند وصولها إلى snehu rivka
على الطريق المؤدي إلى ابنها بقايا
الانعكاس السريع لروسيا Under Fire
قبل يومين ، تشير الكثير من الذخيرة غير المنفجرة
هنا إلى قذائف الهاون القاتلة إلى
أنه كان من الممكن أن يقاتلوا لفترة أطول إذا
لم يُطلب منهم التراجع وهو يقود
كل شخص يلوح بمشاعر كثيرة  في كل
مرة ، استعاد الاحتفال بالراحة والصدمات ،
لقد كان أمرًا فظيعًا ، أخبرتنا أن
الروس هددوني بقتلي لتحطيم
عواطف دماغي الخام في كل مكان ، حيث يعيش
الأقارب البائون وهم يعرفون بعضهم البعض
وتلك قصص البقاء على قيد الحياة
تقشعر لها الأبدان
قبل أيام قليلة ، اختطفني الروس
تخبرنا هذه الفتاة البالغة من العمر 15 عامًا أنهم
وضعوا غطاء للرأس على وجهي وأخذوني إلى منزل سألني فيه
عن الأوكرانية  أخبرني السادة أنهم
سيقطعون أصابعي
اعتقدت أنني سأتعرض للاغتصاب
مثل الحيوانات في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ،
قالت إنهم أخذوا الناس
للاستجواب وضربوهم
متهمينهم بأنهم جواسيس أوكرانيون ، سرقوا
السيارات ونهبوا أيضًا
في البلدة.  بنك ، أبواب الأمن ،
مزق النقود أيضًا ، يمكنك أن ترى في
الداخل هنا البنك
محطّم تمامًا نهبًا ، وهناك صناديق نقود تم
فتحها في ساحة المدينة ،
وتجمع الناس في جزء من الابتهاج
في حالة من عدم اليقين في المدينة بدون
ماء وكهرباء
لأشهر وصلوا حديثًا
أخبرهم المسؤول الأوكراني أن
الإمدادات الإنسانية في طريقها
إلى ضواحي سكان البلدة
المستفيدين من التراجع السريع لروسيا.
تقدم الأوكرانية جنوبًا
نحو ابنها
، لا يبدو أن هذا التكتيك ينجح
في تقدم أوكرانيا ح  حيث كانت
فترات توقف حذر لإعادة تجميع صفوفهم وإعادة تنشيطهم ، لكن
لا يزال
كل شيء يحدث بلا هوادة وفقًا
للخطة التي يغادرها الروس بسرعة كبيرة لدرجة
أنهم يفقدون أحذيتهم أثناء السباق ،
وسوف نأخذها في غضون يومين أو ثلاثة
أيام ، وقد يكون ذلك قبل ذلك.  بعد ثوانٍ من
حديثنا ، تلقوا دعوة للمضي قدمًا
في طريقهم ، يبدو أنه ينضمون إلى The
Liberation والاحتفالات في
أغنيتها وأنت تعلم أعتقد أنه يمكننا أن نتوقع
أن تستمر تلك الاحتفالات وهذا الشعور
بالنشوة لبعض الوقت ولكن
الحكومة تحث أيضًا  تحذير من إخبار
سكان هيرسوم السابقين بعدم العودة ،
لكن الأمر ليس آمنًا ، فقد تكون هناك
ألغام على الأسلحة المتفجرة ، إنه أمر
خطير للغاية وبالطبع لدى الحكومة
أولويات أخرى تحتاج إلى النظر في
ذلك السد والتأكد
من عدم وجوده.  سيكون هناك
فيضان كبير لهارون